you absolutely have to see this
interview from last night with
california
uh potential california gubernatorial
candidate caitlyn jenner
of course of the kardashians fame former
olympian uh as bruce jenner earlier in
life now caitlyn jenner worth 100
million dollars
personally by most reports and that
becomes very relevant during the
interview
the current california governor is
democrat gavin newsom there's an
effort to recall gavin newsom in order
to do this
californians need to collect just shy of
1.5
million signatures to have a recall
it appears they've done it they've
collected 1.6 million but those
signatures now
have to be validated uh signers also
have 30 days to say
actually i signed it but i don't want to
be on the list anymore
so at some point relatively soon we will
see
will the recall be happening now if
indeed it happens caitlyn jenner has
announced
uh that she is running caitlyn jenner is
notable
because she is a trans woman and a
republican although how much she knows
about politics is in question
and you will notice that in this
interview of course the republican party
hasn't been very good to the trans
community
many have been outright hostile to the
trans community in many ways including
on the bathroom issue for years now so
jenner was interviewed last
night by sean hannity and the
combination
of completely unrelatable comments about
private jets with sean hannity
and hannity just looking so
uncomfortable with the interview makes
this one of the most compelling
political interviews in a long time
i was watching these clips over and over
again last night like there's a pruder
film preparing for today
so let's jump right in in this first
clip caitlyn jenner tells us
listen we've got to solve these problems
in california
because you know what my neighbor at my
hangar where i keep my private plane
he's thinking of leaving and i'm
thinking of leaving if we don't improve
things
think of the private plane owners
this you have to see california my
friends are leaving california
actually wearing my hanger the guy
across front of roof and he was packing
up his hangers where are you going
and he says i'm moving to sedona arizona
i can't take it
anymore i can't walk down the streets
and see the homeless
i don't want to leave okay either i
stay and fight or i get out of here
why is no one talking about the
marginalized
oppressed private plane owners thinking
of leaving
this is how bad it is in california guys
the private plane owners
they are having to see homeless people
on the way to their hangar
and that that is just terrible uh the
private plane
owners are this close to packing up
their private jets
and flying somewhere else and caitlyn
jenner is going to keep them in
california if elected governor okay so
off to a blazing fast start as you can
see
and this is nothing it gets even worse
now
of course caitlyn jenner was asked by
hannity about
transgender girls in sports republicans
know almost nothing about the trans
community
but the two things they know about and
care about are trans bathroom laws
and trans girls in sports those are the
two trans issues for republicans
caitlyn jenner's answer is a complete
mystery to me i've watched this
three times i'm gonna watch it now a
fourth time with you i can't make heads
or tails
out of this answer take a look um i
stick with my statements that i made
um i think um we have to make sure
that the integrity of girl sports is
there
i think that's extremely important
but it's there's more to it than just
what i said
because i just said biological boys in
sports
there's more to it than that and i think
in the future i will explain
more of that but for me as a
a trans woman
i think role models are extremely
important for young people
trans issues people struggle with big
time our suicide rate is nine times
higher than the general public
and um for me to be a role model for
them
to be out there i am running
for governor of the state of california
who would have ever thunked that we've
never even had
a woman uh
governor but some are mad at you that's
that's i don't you know i move on
i want to be a role model and i think
the and to be a leader
and i think the most important thing as
a leader
that you can do is your compassion your
honesty
um and i think that sometimes is very
lacking
in politics so uh i want to be an
example
uh to all people not just trans people
but this is what
why on the sports side of it though why
did
how you came down on the sports side of
the issue
i don't know why to be honest with you i
don't know why they keep asking matt
what do you think sean i don't know
why do they keep asking me that question
uh
great question it is a good question so
what on earth is her position
on the issue of trans girls and sports
imagine being a republican and thinking
this is great
a trans candidate finally we are going
to get clarity
what is caitlyn jenner's position on
trans girls in sports
what would caitlyn jenner do as governor
about trans girls in sports and then you
hear that
and you come out even more confused
and then this is just straight out of a
comedy show
sean hannity asks caitlyn jenner's
position
on forest fires and this is i mean you
know
what on earth would caitlyn jenner know
about that issue but it's a big issue in
california if you're going to run for
governor
of california you need an answer to this
because forest fires really are an issue
and her answer is almost verbatim a
trump answer about oh you've got to do
forest management
and would you allow controlled burns
isn't there a science behind
forestry is that science being ignored
in this state
yes because when i watch it man heart i
lived in santa barbara i watched hope
branch
hope ranch burned down after i had just
left the state
yes um uh yes forest management is
extremely important
yeah just like at my house and it's not
even forest management at my house
the reason my house made it because they
say you have to keep
any brush 50 or 75 feet i think i had 75
feet clearance
when the fires came they just went
around my house so fast
it was gone because it's moving very
fast so
it's almost the same thing for forest
management just a little bit of
preparation
so there it is i mean guys just just do
the forest management
and everything will be fine why this is
so why do we keep talking about this
just manage the forest and that's
it and if you thought that was trumpian
in this next clip caitlyn jenner
takes credit for governor gavin newsom
loosening covid restrictions which is
completely out of the trump playbook
take credit for things that have nothing
to do with you
and the really funny thing is jenner
says you know if i were governor i'd
open the state tomorrow
if the recall happens it's months away
california is opening in five weeks
so the the caitlyn jenner would open the
state tomorrow
except the recall is months away and
california will be open by then take a
look
would you open the state of california
completely tomorrow
absolutely open it right up actually you
know what it's
just don't close in and out burger
before i leave it's even on a small
scale kind of working already
about three weeks ago uh it was rumored
and rightfully so it was rumored that i
was looking in to run for governor
the next day gavin newsom has a press
conference says the state is opening up
july 15th
i'm laying there in bed and watching
this and i'm saying yes
it's already working so there it is
caitlyn jenner
may be responsible for covid
restrictions loosening in july
all bizarre and then hannity asks jenner
for an assessment of trump biden and
harris when this happened
i you know i got the popcorn and got got
ready
and her explanation about why trump good
biden bad it's the exact
meaningless vapid drivel we hear from
trumpists take a look at this
we've had four years of donald trump we
have joe biden and kamala harris
give me your assessment of those three
people
um what i liked about donald trump
as he was a disrupter you know
he came in and shook the system up
okay a lot of people didn't like that
and
washington dc but he came in and shook
the system up
i think he did some things that i agreed
with some things i didn't agree with i i
you're critical on transgender issues on
trans issues lgbt issues i was more
hopeful at the beginning
and but there were some good things he
did
on the other hand biden i don't think
i've agreed with anything i don't think
since he's been in there he has done
anything for the american worker
maybe other ones so um it is a
it is a 180 degree turn in our country
uh going the other direction and and uh
it scares me it's almost verbatim what
we've heard from for a long time
trump was different he shook things up
he wasn't a politician it was a new
direction
it's just meaningless vapid dribble
once again and then maybe my favorite
clip
of the entire interview this is the
wrap-up hannity
thanks caitlyn jenner for doing the
interview
and jenner brings up the private plane
again and says let's go for a flight
and hannity just looks visibly
uncomfortable
caitlyn jenner thank you for being with
us it was my pleasure
always a pleasure to talk to you so talk
to you good to see you again now
we're going to go find my plane around
the corner i'm gonna take you for a
flight
i'm going right his wheels up any minute
all right all right
uh thank you for your time uh we do wish
you nothing but the best we're gonna
follow this race closely
so there it is just a strange interview
trumpian
in many ways completely lacking in
substance
completely absent was any serious policy
discussion and i
watched this entire thing i don't know
why caitlyn jenner is running for
governor
it's not clear to me what caitlyn jenner
brings
to the table as a gubernatorial
candidate but seeing republicans
uh on the one hand they want to remove
gavin newsom
but at the same time many of them
dislike trans people as much as they
dislike gavin newsom
and now they've got a transgender
republican candidate i guess running if
the recall ends up happening
they're in a tizzy they don't know up is
down down is up it's bizarro world for
them so we're going to follow the
california situation very interesting to
see
and one of the most unusual interviews
i've ever seen
we'll have clips of it on our instagram
page as well
follow us there at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
letting my audience try it free for an
entire
month i love curiosity stream perfect
for people
like me or anybody who watches the david
pakman show
curiosity stream is kind of like netflix
for documentaries it's a streaming
service with thousands of documentaries
from some of the best filmmakers
many are exclusive to curiosity stream
including documentaries on politics
science history
everything the curiosity stream app is
great i use it on my tv
phone and ipad i just watched as i told
you
uh very recently engineering the future
very very interesting about potential
future technologies
and they always have the newest and most
popular documentaries
they have amazing ones that i can't find
on other platforms and curiosity stream
is just 299 a month
or 19.99 for a whole year but
you can try it totally free for one
month
when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman
and use the promo code pacman